what inspires me I believe it's
important that you are inspired as an
entrepreneur you're starting the
business around your passion if you
don't you're not gonna have success if
you're in it just for the money it's not
gonna work out for you I got a tweet
from one of my followers Bob Narinder
who is at Bob Narenda and he wrote in to
say so what inspires you
was there a Eureka moment that sent you
on your current path and there was so
here's what happened with my business
okay I had a software company and I
built it up I sold it when I sold it I
was kind of struggling I didn't know
what I wanted to do next you know I put
so much of myself into this business
that I needed I don't know I needed
something else to do but I didn't know
where to go and I felt like just
exploring and I tried a whole bunch of
different things and one of the ones
that came up was I talked to the YMCA a
local YMCA group and we talked about
doing a presentation where I come in and
talk about entrepreneurship young
entrepreneurs and and how to make your
dream of starting the business a reality
and they said we have this group for
entrepreneurs we have a young
entrepreneur program we'd love to have
you come and speak to them so I said
great no prob like no cost I'm just
doing this to give back and to explore
and and to help and see where it leads
and I remember I got so excited about
this I was I was making a presentation
and I I spent about a month I think
making this thing what the size were
gonna be what I was gonna talk about and
I was promoting it and the YMCA was
promoting it and about a month and
there's a free presentation and I
remember the day comes like today is a
day I'm gonna go do my presentation at
the Y you know we'll see what leads to
and my heart's pounding and I'm nervous
a little bit I hadn't done a lot of
speaking before this and I remember
getting to the door and going up the
elevator and and just getting all
excited and I go in I open the door walk
into the room when we said this huge
room up full of chairs and three people
were in the room and and I felt like
that the air was just sucked out of my
lungs like I'd spent so much time
promoting this and the YMCA promoted it
and working on the content and three
people showed up for a free event it's
like what and and it was really
heartbreaking you know I felt in that
moment like maybe I made the wrong
decision like this maybe was a stupid
thing for me to do like I had wasted a
lot of my time I hate wasting time and I
felt like this probably was a waste of
time so I continued on you know there's
three people still shut up I did this
work I need to at least deliver the
presentation and then ended up being
awesome i I went through my content and
because it was such a small group I got
to know everybody really well and got to
help them with their problems and the
challenges they faced and they laughed
as different people than when they came
in and even though it was only three
people that made me feel really good
like I knew that I had helped these
people that day and I gave them advice
that nobody else had given them before
and and I could help be the difference
between them succeeding and them not
making it with their company and that
made me feel really good and from there
I had to find the way to keep doing it
if it was presentations or websites or
videos like this or on Twitter or
Facebook or YouTube or whatever I didn't
know where would lead only that I had to
keep doing this work to help
entrepreneurs you know before I would
sound like biotech software I had
nothing to do with entrepreneurship but
I felt like after that experience I had
I had to I had to help other
entrepreneurs that was my Eureka moment
and everybody looking at that situation
might have said Evan you're kind of
crazy right like you could only get
three people to come out to a free event
that was you and the YMCA promoting it
and all three people came out like how
is this ever gonna be a business and and
I didn't have the answer like I didn't
know how I would eventually make money
from this and entrepreneurs don't have
money so how do you turn that like
logically this didn't make any sense to
get into like Evan what are you doing
this is stupid
where
with my biotech software company I'm
selling the huge companies like Knotts
and Johnson Johnson guys with huge
budgets but there was just something
about it that I loved doing and I I
don't know I don't know I think I would
have taken the job just to make money to
to do this you know I love doing it so
much and so I knew I had to continue I
had no idea what the form would look
like I had no idea what built this
popular website that eventually be on
YouTube I had no idea any of that was
gonna happen I just knew that I had to
continue it and I think that's when you
have that moment it's a very exciting
but also dangerous time because if you
think too logically if I thought just
with my head I wouldn't have continued
right I wouldn't have made sense
logically it doesn't make sense to do
this if I talk to people about it and
they looked at you know the stats and
the market research it wouldn't have
made any sense like what you're doing
you can't you can't make money from this
entrepreneurs don't have money and even
if they did you only got three people to
a free event like it didn't make any
sense and that's where for a lot of
entrepreneurs their ideas die and they
they side with everybody else this yeah
you know what you're probably right that
was a stupid idea I should have done
that where there's still something like
hey you know what maybe there was a way
to make it work you know you kind of you
feel like there's something that could
have could have worked out and so I
didn't give up on my idea even though I
had no idea how it would work out and
because you often don't have all the
answers at the beginning you start to
doubt yourself and I guess don't doubt
yourself right and and it's okay not
having all the answers yet and it's okay
that you're gonna struggle and it's okay
that nobody comes to your event and it's
okay that you're not making money yet
you don't have the answers yet you're
working on it but you you will figure it
out if you keep going and you keep
following your passion you will figure
it out it's going to take longer than
you want it to take it might cost more
money than you want it to take you know
we're inpatient we want things now but
it will work out if you keep following
your passion so that's my story that's
kind of my unique I guess Eureka moment
and thank you for asking the question so
for those you watching you like the
video please give a thumbs up below if
you have a question for me or if you
want to share your Eureka moment please
leave it in the comment section below
I love seeing those come in they really
make my day every time they do and if
you want to see more videos like this
you can click on my face up there and
subscribe to this channel thank you so
much and I'll see you soon